all right i have a lot of questions and
then we're i guess i'm going to learn
yes there's nothing i can't do so uh
except pole dance uh very excited about
it why is it called the s factor called
the s factor after the shape of a
woman's body the curves of the s kind of
mimic the shape of a woman's body as
opposed to like a man who's more like of
an h
we're an age
thanks a lot
women are an ass
h
that's true you guys are more linear and
square most workouts
are linear and very square and right
this is a just a very different way of
moving your body into your curves right
and can and can a man i mean i'll be
trying to do this but can a man learn to
become an s if he's an
h i love the idea of trying to teach you
how to do this i've taught a few men a
few men and and so we'll see we'll see
how it goes now you started doing pole
dancing this is a quite a while ago and
you installed a poll
in your house i did when you first got
started you went out and you got a
stripper pole and installed it in the
house how did your husband react to that
well the only room i could i could fit
it in was his office and i had to put it
i know i had to put it between um his
stair master and the tv right and he was
very unhappy about it was like no get
the pole out right no no that's so weird
you're you're stripping is blocking the
tv
there we go it lasted for about um about
17 minutes right and then you know i
started working out and then he was like
he was fine with him he was moved out
and then you you moved stripper poles to
different parts of the house how many
are there in the house right now i have
four four i do four stripper poles
throughout the house i do okay this is
cool i have three in my bedroom two in
my bedroom two in your bedroom so you
can fly from one to the other
wing wang
that's exciting that's exciting i have
one in the family room and one on my
patio patio yes what are the neighbors
who are barbecuing doing when you're in
the strip pole
i don't know i haven't seen them yet i
haven't met them yet we just moved into
this one okay so you're going to get
people looking over the hedges
i think we might and you wear do you
wear the you wear some sexy stuff while
you're
yeah yeah yeah it's it we have it's like
a little strip of shorts so yes you work
on the pole yeah you need to have your
legs bare when you're climbing and doing
work up on the pole right right it's
really it's the most amazing workout you
have ever done yeah well i have ever
done all right and you can just work
every muscle in your body okay i have
like two muscles in my body
and one of them just doesn't work at all
that was bad uh
let's
touch that one baby let's go let's do
this right now let's uh let's find out
what's going on you tell me what i need
to do we got a stripper pole here and
what do i need to should i
do anything
move the jacket
i'm getting i'm getting my ass going uh
should the shoes go too yeah take the
shoes off all right great the first
thing i want to do is i want to warm
your body up because whenever you do any
pull work you want to be warm
okay what do we do put your back up put
your your back up against the pole my
back right here okay your upper back and
then walk your feet out on your toes
like right here yeah now go up on your
toes okay and get your hips way out like
me
good that's
excellent a minute now take you know can
you see me take your hair i can't feel
anything
take your hip to the right to the right
okay push it push it push it push it and
then inhale take your butt all the way
back against the pole nice conan
look at me four seconds forward push it
forward that way okay oh that way all
right yeah that way now come around one
more time
up on your toes okay i can't i okay
that broke a few things that was a
stretch
that was just a stretch right there
getting warmed up here
i want you to start
okay
i'm loose now okay i'm going to teach
you your first trick liquid snake what's
that that means that was really good
okay just slow it down a little bit okay
slow it down all right so i wanted you
to the first trick okay you go call it a
firefly
your right hand's above your head left
hand's over here
you're going to swing your left hand
foot and
fly it's not going to look like that
it's not going to look anything like
that take your hand over your head all
right okay okay all right what am i
doing i'm going to swing your left hand
under your right hand under my right
hand yeah and then swing your left foot
hook it and throw your body to me and
throw my
put my whole body at you throw your
whole body that's a lot of man coming
your way baby
here we go come on come on go go
all right all right we're gonna try one
more trick i had a small heart attack
during that
like halfway through it's just stopped i
love your technique it's great i want
you to work on your your landings make
them more fluid oh okay
all right we're going to try the body
spiral what's that take your isn't that
the body spiral what's the firefly okay
body spiral you're going to come out
swing out oh my god
okay that's not going to happen and see
how i'm landing
okay
you do
yeah
you look incredibly sexy when you're
doing these things so what tell me what
to do i'm wearing so you're going to
step this foot over here uh-huh and then
you're going to grab the po up here oh
pull the pole under your arm i'm going
to push pull the pole under my arm yeah
go now just okay what am i going to do
i'm going to throw your body that way
throw my body that way okay here we go
[Music]
my god
okay
is the pole supposed to move around like
that
what the hell is going on here i'm
really really impressed we're gonna do a
move that doesn't require spinning okay
okay what do you want me to do call the
snake okay
left hand over there oh i know the snake
okay go ahead
you're gonna lift your left leg
you're gonna lift your left leg up yeah
you're gonna curl up remember the ending
is the landing is the most important
part right yes yes of course
oh my god
you're gonna let yourself just slowly
come down the pole and when you land
you're gonna like be a wet piece of
spaghetti you're just gonna be a wet
piece of spaghetti
slow
i don't even think i can get upside down
i don't think i can get upside down no i
really don't okay you're gonna have to
help me with this one what do i do this
foot you're gonna hook this ankle up
there yeah it's never my my leg has
never been up above this position right
now you're gonna curl up go all right go
uh
spaghetti
that's good do you want to try one more
i know i think we're out of time and i
have to get the blood back down here
that was incredible i like that i really
did yeah you got a fly high you know
what uh there's another reason uh
you